yola the capital of adamawa state in
northeast nigeria for days refugees have
been flooding into the city fleeing boko
haram's latest wave of violence
many who arrive are deeply traumatized
one of the new arrivals is hanatu marcus
she fled her village after it was
overrun by islamist militants on the
road she lost a son her husband was
murdered
when boko haram came to our village my
husband hid in the bush for four days
because they were forcing men to fight
with them
tens of thousands have been forced to
flee many are taken in by relatives
others end up in refugee camps like the
one here in yola
my life has been completely destroyed
and that makes me so sad
i used to have my husband but he was
killed
now i have nothing
i don't know how things can go on
in a new video boko haram are seen
celebrating the taking of yet another
town the group's leader abubakar shakao
again declares there will be no
negotiations with the government
last month nigerian officials announced
a ceasefire deal but that was later
refuted by the militants
the nigerian army is now planning a new
offensive in the northeast to stop boko
haram's latest advance
you